[Música]
y llegó la hora de hablar de economía en
directo américa para eso nos acompaña
daniela blandón daría el agua el lunes
para usted un lunes bastante movido en
las noticias no bastante movida siempre
los lunes son un poco flojos pero hoy
estuvo muy movido maría clara y hablemos
de la primera decepción que rompió la
regla de las noticias que se están
moviendo porque vienen desde reino unido
tenemos una nueva primera ministra
listos cuáles son los principales retos
que lleva a enfrentar en materia
económica bueno maría clara es que ella
se enfrenta a una situación económica
que no es nada fácil como no está nada
fácil tampoco en los otros países de
europa y es que hay quienes también
comparan esta situación con la que
recibió margaret thatcher en 1979 y que
trajo las políticas de libre mercado que
definieron su legado y que perduran
hasta hoy listos hoy recibe entonces una
economía que se dirige a una recesión
potencialmente por prolongada y también
una creciente alza en el costo de vida
que ya pasa el 10% interanual por
primera vez desde la década de los 80
adicionalmente la factura energética
de los hogares del reino unido- podrá
aumentar hasta en un 80 por ciento en
octubre a casi el triple del nivel de
hace un año veamos más la situación es
tal que el grupo de expertos del
instituto nacional de investigación
económica y social estima que 1 de cada
5 hogares británicos no va a tener
ahorros para 2024 y el actual ministro
de finanzas advirtió que las personas
que ganan 45.000 libras esos son unos 52
mil dólares al año y está también muy
por encima del promedio de 31 mil libras
al año pues estas personas podrían
enfrentar dificultades para pagar sus
facturas escuchamos también que piensa
la gente en reinounido de este nuevo
líder que fue escogido ya no se trata
sólo de personas sin hogar son las
familias trabajadoras las que ahora
encuentran muy muy difícil alimentar a
sus hijos por lo tanto nuestras
consultas a menudo vienen acompañadas de
un estoy realmente avergonzado de
preguntar o nunca he tenido que hacer
esto antes hay muchas personas que
honestamente nunca han tenido que pedir
ayuda en sus vidas antes de ser verts
eelv hawks hasta ayer trabajé para una
organización ayudaba a las familias con
problemas difíciles tuvimos que cerrar
porque se retiró la financiación y esta
es un área donde hay muchos problemas y
problemas cuando yo creo que es algo que
los políticos no entienden no viven esas
vidas cuando están un gran reto del que
tiene otros y que desde ya está siendo
comparada con thatcher incluso en las
crisis y hablando de crisis la situación
energética puede empeorar de hecho rusia
está culpando a occidente de ser el
responsable de la parálisis del envío de
gas bueno pues es que recordemos marcará
que el mayor productor de gas ruso que
es gazprom anunció el viernes que había
detenido indefinidamente su suministro a
través del gasoducto nord stream 1
debido a fallas en una unidad compresora
ya lo habían ya lo habían suspendido
pero se suponía que el sábado volvía a
entrar en funcionamiento y no fue así
materializó entonces de esta manera los
temores de europa que acusa a moscú de
usar el gas como arma política y que
sigue sufriendo las consecuencias por
ejemplo el euro cae hoy a mínimos de 20
años frente al dólar aunque el rublo
también se está desvalorizando ha sido
la moneda de mejor desempeño del mundo
este año pero hoy se debilita frente al
dólar el kremlin entonces salió en su
propia defensa y esto fue lo que dijo el
vocero y
los problemas con el suministro de gas
surgieron debido a las sanciones
impuestas a nuestro país ya varias
empresas rusas por parte de los estados
occidentales incluidos alemania y gran
bretaña no hay otras razones que
conduzcan a problemas con el suministro
obviamente la única turbina está
funcionando pero está funcionando mal
allí se producen roturas y eso provoca
cortes de suministro
gandín agregó bueno daniela una
situación bastante difícil sobre todo
porque se aproxima el invierno que con
las reservas de gas que tiene europa va
a ser bastante difícil cuál es la
situación europea claro va a ser muy
difícil porque europa depende en gran
medida del gas del gas ruso ha venido
buscando otras fuentes ha traído de
otros países pero en este momento una de
las soluciones que encuentra es traer
gas natural licuado que resulta bastante
costoso y bastante lejano también traer
gas natural desde eeuu no es lo mismo ni
es igual de costoso que traerlo desde
rusia a través de un gasoducto entonces
va a resultar no solamente más escaso el
gas sino más caro además se ha dicho que
no tiene las suficientes barcazas para
recibir todo este gas que le viene gas
natural licuado que además tienen que
tener plantas de reclasificación para
poderlo utilizar
así que estamos en una situación
bastante difícil aunque los líderes han
dicho han dado partes de
tranquilidad pero pues ya veremos qué
ocurre en el invierno y la situación es
tan difícil que incluso en otros países
como república checa que dependen en
gran medida del gas y del petróleo ruso
ya le están diciendo su gobierno que se
considere
dios del gas de rusia esto qué quiere
decir decirle le compró su casa a
determinado precio a partir de ese
precio no le sigo comprando entonces él
cree mí lo que ha dicho es si ustedes me
van a poner un tope al precio pues yo no
le sigo vendiendo gas y no sólo el
precio del gas está disparado porque
también los alimentos se están afectando
y esto está impactando a somalia que
está al borde de la hambruna simari
claro pues el jefe humanitario de
naciones unidas martin griffiths resumió
en pocas palabras lo que le esperaría a
unos 20 millones de personas escuchamos
me ha conmocionado profundamente estos
últimos días el nivel de dolor y
sufrimiento que vemos soportar a tantos
somalíes
en la hambruna está a la puerta y hoy
recibimos una advertencia
cuando gómez la hambruna entonces
llegaría el próximo otoño
aproximadamente octubre en partes del
centro y del sur del país a medida que
los precios mundiales de los alimentos
como usted lo dice también están en
niveles históricos y el cuerno de áfrica
experimenta su peor sequía en 40 años y
es que maría clara los expertos dicen
que la región está en camino de una
quinta temporada de lluvias fallida
consecutiva en 2011 el país ya había
experimentado una hambruna que cobró más
de 250 mil vidas la mayoría de ellos
niños
daniela y vamos con la cifra de este
lunes 5 de septiembre maría clara 80,21
esa fue la inflación interanual de
turquía en agosto de este año según la
oficina de estadísticas sin embargo
expertos independientes como el grupo de
investigación de inflación dicen que la
cifra es mucho más alta la sitúan en 181
por ciento porque se da esta situación
porque el banco central volvió a
recortar las tasas de interés el mes
pasado algo que los economistas más
ortodoxos consideran la causa de los
males turcos pues va en contra de lo que
está haciendo el resto de bancos
centrales del mundo y qué es lo que está
haciendo el banco en los bancos
centrales como la reserva federal
subiendo tasas de esta manera
desincentivan el consumo y enfrían un
poco la economía para que la inflación
vaya bastante complejo el panorama
económico como siempre daniela gracias
por toda la información nosotros
continuamos en directo américa